one of the people that's been
disappearing for a long time that every
time somebody brings it up and Leah
Remini brought it up and hey you don't
ask about this who do you think you are
to ask about where is his wife I mean
the last time they're saying what was
the number they said 2009 they showed up
and in 2012 or 13 2013 is the last time
they saw his wife it's been nine years
where is his wife no one sees his wife
anywhere David miscavige's wife his wife
is missing for a long time she's not
been seen in over a decade yeah 13 2013.
she she has been disappeared
and I mean I just know in the book of
Bible Enoch was taken by God and there's
a couple characters that were that never
died they were taken right
I don't know if you understand where I'm
going here with this one where is she
she is
um holed up in one of the Scientology
facilities in the San Bernardino
Mountains last I knew that's where she
was taken at least at the outset
um this is a very secret location that
Scientology has
um and it is the headquarters of a
particular organization in Scientology
called The Church of spiritual
technology which is an organization that
is dedicated to preserving the writings
and words of lrun Hubbard for eternity
etched onto stainless steel plates uh
held in titanium containers filled with
Argon gas covered with gold uh
space shuttle tile material and buried
in volts dug into the ground across the
the United States but that's the
headquarters of it and it is a super
secure compound and
she was taken there because she began to
question the choices and Sanity of her
husband
and displeased him in whatever fashion
and I talk about that in the book and my
interactions with with Shelley and one
of the last interactions I had with her
when she had been left at the gold
property which is where the hole was up
in Riverside County and David was down
in Los Angeles and I had gone to see him
about something and came back and she
wanted to see me right away and I went
to see her and she sort of notionally
asked or tried to not generally ask in
the conversation did you notice if Dave
was wearing his gold or his platinum
wedding ring and it was like uh
Shelley seriously you're worried about
whether Dave is still wearing a wedding
ring oh [ __ ] things are bad and she
vanished very shortly there what year
was this 2005.
and how was she how was she as an
individual
um a lot of people found her to be uh uh
I don't know
cold and sort of nasty I had known her
since she was 12 years old on the Apollo
I had a very different relationship with
her she was always very kind to me I
talk in the book about Shelley coming to
wake me up to tell me that I had to go
to Clearwater because my child had died
this is her right here yes that's a
they're not very flattering photographs
those photographs by the way but
she is
and and oddly she looks almost in that
big one she looks almost like Mary Sue
Hubbard a very similar look to Mary Sue
Hubbard at her age and I was gonna make
the point Patrick that elrond Hubbard
also disappeared his wife
Mary Sue Hubbard was the head of the
guardian's office which was the
predecessor of the office of special
Affairs which I became the head of
look at that redhead curly hair yeah and
that was sold a similar facial feet you
know that thin sort of very interesting
but can you go back to a picture of what
uh David miscavige looks like and
correct me if I'm wrong he doesn't do
interviews at all these days he did one
he did how long ago was that uh 2003 or
something so he hasn't done an interview
in 20 years almost
correct and that's intentional obviously
he does not want to be what seen heard
what he's actually actually really want
to know where you're going with the wife
because you're saying the similarities
between uh miscavige's wife and L Ron
Hubbard's wife what were similarities so
she was trying to and then she also
disappeared why did L Ron Hubbard's wife
disappear because elrond Hubbard's wife
was in charge of the guardian's office
and ended up being prosecuted along with
10 other senior officials of Scientology
for infiltrating the U.S government
and
um seeking uh infiltrating like planting
spies and stealing documents tapping the
IRS uh conference room and various other
things and she was prosecuted and ended
up going to prison when she got out of
Hubbard believed that Mary Sue and all
these people that were in the Guardians
office who had been doing exactly what
he laid out to do in his writings about
how to deal with the enemies of
Scientology had created an uh a threat
to him a personal threat that he may be
dragged into this he was named as an
unindicted co-conspiracy by the doj in
that prosecution he never they could
never pin anything on him because every
one of the people from Mary Sue down
said oh El Ron hubba didn't know
anything about this which was [ __ ]
he did
but he believed that Mary Sue was now a
big threat to him and that the
government may be able to get to him
through Mary Sue so she was put in a
home a house that was uh in Los Feliz in
Los Angeles and had a household staff
that was provided and reported to David
miscavich and he never saw her again
and he never even communicated with her
again there was no written communication
even it used to be that when they were
in separate locations that they would
write letters to one another and The
Messengers which I was talking about the
the people that were with Hubbard on a
day-to-day basis used to answer those
and then eventually he said I want to
hear from her anymore and they didn't
even get responded to or if they did he
never even saw them his own wife was
having letters written to her by her
husband who were actually composed by
people like me commodore's Messengers
um
miscavige believed that Shelley was a
threat to him because for a long long
time Shelley had been by miscavige's
side whenever miscavige went anywhere
Shelley was there she was the cob which
is what he calls himself the chairman of
the board even though he's not actually
on the board because he doesn't want to
get served through corporate means
but cob assistant was Shelley and
Shelley was with Dave everywhere Shelley
was the one that hired the people for
Tom Cruise's household Shelley was the
one that would accompany Dave to well
Shelley was there with Dave and two or
three other people when Tom married
Nicole
in Telluride
that they were inseparable
Shelley then became convinced that maybe
Dave was off the rails and there are a
few other things that came up with you
know her not carrying out his wishes and
so he perceived her as a threat because
if there was one person in Scientology
that the the leading officials like
myself or Norman Starkey or Guillaume Le
Serv or the other people who had
prominent positions in Scientology if
there was one person that people would
listen to In addition to David it was
Shelley they trusted her absolutely and
the ones like us that like me that had
known her for way longer than we'd known
Dave trusted her perhaps more than Dave
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]